[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un coûteux manque aucune écurie de
jeunes à dire qu'après tout c'est
honteux promettait des 1000 coups de
batte au pardon à réfléchir non
wasquehal oui tu vois ce que je veux ici
de m'améliorer mais les chiens monde est
battue si c'est lui que je me suis fait
faire pour être le plus beau et s'ils
retiennent pas grand yaka je vais la
chercher
c'est la première fois que je mets cette
robe de chambre
je les ai pas le plus beau moitié votre
nouvelle robe de chambre et ceux ci
quotas j'aimais des monstres aviez me
faire l'essayage et tu va convoquer tout
le monde est heureux que vous soyez tous
autour de moi pour m'admirer y est mais
je me rapproche des grands yaka et celle
est ici le plus joyeux mais c'est que
j'ai la peau si délicatement cette
couleur et elle vous aviez assez si
bonne et je suis si bon et c'est vrai je
suis trop beauté cette robe de chambre
va être le triomphe de ma vie grandjack
à tout le monde il l'a c'est bien je
suis très content à les oscars vient
m'aider là pour voir ça qu'on nous
vendait ranvin silence mongeau dabistes
au spectacle commence
voyez un grand yaka les manches sont
parfaites mais je me sers de bienne pour
les brasser ses titres et c'est très
réussi
tu as des monstres quoi il était longue
date à vos gardes le train de partir
cette époque la cave chats des ports et
moi je vois bien les talonnent mais je
ne peux pas marcher
le premier c'est que dès que je fais un
peu chacun veut se dessine je m'excuse
sucrant chacun vous êtes tous des
traîtres des incapables des barbares
désignera vous aurez tous du même coup
de bâton voilà je mets ma robe de
chambre ce soir et s'il est encore tôt
l'homme vous aurez tout se dit que le
coup de bâton j'ai compris
du coup de patte ans et ça donne à
réfléchir ne voyons plus qu'elle est
trop longue et pour la raccourcir et oui
je suis un artiste doit bon soyons
losciste plus qu'à la trop longue il
faut la raccourci gibier coûte pas un
sou au quel déshonneur à l'ambassade est
proche
ça dépend il faut la raccourcir mais oui
oh
[Musique]
voilà un petit boulot dodo et elle est
par m
[Musique]
raccourci sans un petit coup de ciseau
problème dit bill coups de bâton et
l'erreur
[Musique]
juste un petit coup du physio et nous
éviterons les coups de barre action
[Musique]
les robes et les chèvres mais il y en a
plus mais d'en couper movement in which
amateurs chômage
vous aurez samir volumateur pour un
petit coup de couteau ça fait beaucoup
de monde m'attend et après c'est une
autre histoire